♫
♫ ♫
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
LIT THE BUREAUCRATIC FUSE FOR
HIS NEW SPACE COMMAND BUT THE
IDEA COMES WITH A HEFTY PRICE
TAG AND PLENTY OF CRITICS.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN LOOKS AT BOTH
SIDES FROM THE PENTAGON.
>> THIS WILL BE THE 11TH COMBAT
AND COMMANDED THE U.S. MILITARY.
>> THE ANNOUNCEMENT WAS TIMED TO
COINCIDE WITH THE LAUNCH OF THE
SPACEX FALCON NINE, A
LONG-DELAYED $500 MILLION GPS
SATELLITE FOR THE U.S. MILITARY,
BUT THE MISSION WAS ABORTED
UNTIL WEDNESDAY.
>> I CAN ASSURE YOU SPACE IS THE
PRIORITY OF THIS PRESIDENT AND
THIS VICE PRESIDENT.
>> THE MEMO ESTABLISHING THE
COMMAND IS AN EFFORT TO
CONSOLIDATE SPACE OPERATIONS AND
DEFEND U.S. ASSETS IN SPACE.
SATELLITES THE U.S. RELIES ON
FOR NAVIGATION, COMMUNICATION,
AND SURVEILLANCE.
THE NEW COMMAND IS EXPECTED TO
COST AT LEAST $800 MILLION OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
>> AS YOU WELL KNOW, SPACE IS A
WAR FIGHTING DOMAIN.
CHINA HAS TESTED MISSILES
DESIGNED TO DESTROY SATELLITES,
CHINA AND RUSSIA ARE LOOKING TO
STATION NEW WEAPONS IN SPACE.
>> THE SPACE COMMAND IS A STEP
TOWARDS HIS SPACE FORCE WHICH AT
FIRST THE PENTAGON RESISTED.
>> President Trump: AT MY
DIRECTION, THE PENTAGON IS
WORKING TO CREATE A THE SIXTH
BRANCH OF THE AMERICAN
ARMED FORCES CALLED SPACE FORCE.
>> THE AIR FORCE WHICH OVERSEES
SPACE INITIALLY OPPOSED THE
PRESIDENT’S IDEA.
>> AND I AM ABSOLUTELY IN FAVOR
OF A SEPARATE SPACE COMMAND TO
PROVIDE THAT WAR FIGHTING FOCUS
BUT I’M NOT IN FAVOR OF A
SEPARATE SPACE FORCE, IT’S NOT
NECESSARY.
>> THE U.S. MILITARY HAD A SPACE
COMMAND FROM 1985 THROUGH 2002